San Francisco it happens to be the area
I'm in right now UK
Argentina welcome
from Virginia but now in Bogota Colombia
that's great
Dallas Texas
Arizona
cool
we'll be starting in about a minute and
a half
Michigan
welcome
foreign
all right we're coming up on the bottom
of the hour here in the U.S
let's begin
all right
so this is a career overview we're going
to explore career opportunities and data
analytics I want to start with an
announcement Brian Campbell had to
cancel this morning
due to illness and I apologize for that
I will be taking
over the webinar my name is Stuart Creek
I'm with simply learn
and I'll take you through this uh
presentation
we're also going to try to schedule
another
uh episode of this in the coming months
with uh another
expert
but today we're going to talk about data
analytics and careers in the field
and we'll talk about opportunities that
you can pursue
I'll ask you a few questions along the
way and I'll tell you about a data
analytics certification program
share with you a bonus offer for being
here today with us just for attending
the webinar
I'll take your questions answer them to
the best of my ability
my background is that I've been in
business for more than four decades
held various roles in business analytics
along with marketing
marketing Communications
so I
I'm not an expert in the field but I do
have a background and let's talk about
data analytics
here
if you have questions along the way
please put them into the Q a box
as I'll be doing the presentation I
won't be able to monitor the chat very
closely but if you put them in the Q a
we'll be able to get to those in the Q a
period after at the end of the
presentation
let's talk about data analytics data
analytics is based on principles of
Statistics which you've developed over
the centuries
probability Theory
to observing the normal distribution
um
to laws of large numbers Bay's theorem
the um
1800s brought advances in understanding
correlation regression variants
things that we now know for uh
statistical analysis
and the 1900s the 20th century brought
us into a whole new set of tools that
allow us to use statistics to understand
the meaning behind data to do things
like
Predictive Analytics prescriptive
Analytics
so this is
the basis but the thing that has made
data analytics what it is today is the
development of computing power so
go back to a
really fascinating early example from
um
Charles Menard
did what considered to be one of the
first infographics and it showed
how Napoleon's Army
started off from France went to Moscow
and then came back
and he did a fascinating version of this
that showed based on the geography and
the timeline
the width of these two different colored
shapes
represent where they are Grand Army of
Napoleon went and
how large it was in case so
you see that the main body of the Army
in the beige leaves France some of it
breaks off to other parts of Europe
but when it gets into Russia and goes
deep into the Russian territory
it's already reduced by about three
quarters
um and then the winter in Moscow happens
and the French are forced to retreat
along the way
the Grand Army as you can see the shape
of the uh the black
path
decreases in width
part of the army that had broken off
comes back but then
they continue back on their March back
to France and
just a tiny fraction of the people are
left so through this graphic
starkly illustrates the disaster that
this was
for the invasion of Russia with
Napoleon's Army and so this is
considered to be one of the first
examples of
infographic which is a form of data
analysis communication that takes
data and puts the meaning of that data
into an easily understandable visual
form that's
really a large part of data analytics
today
in the 1800s the Wharton School
Pennsylvania developed beta models for
the economics of canals the Yuri canal
and so forth now in fact they were
contacted by President Roosevelt
1900s to look at the business case for
building the Panama Canal
so they developed a lot of the
analytical tools that looked at business
Analytics
and understanding how you would
be able to make a profit and project
that profit so that was a
an example of both Predictive Analytics
and prescriptive Analytics
then the Census Bureau which had
struggled
after each census every 10 years to
collect the data and correlate it
um
formative or
promoted the introduction of the punch
cart
the punch card had been invented for
controlling
automate looms and
through the efforts of the Census Bureau
they developed the application of the
punch card essence of storing data
so with the punch card and punch card
tabulation they were able to complete
tabulating the 1890s census in the
unheard of space of just 18 months
um
well go forward 50 years 60 years into
the 1950s and 60s and you have
electronic computers
which can now
do the work of many people
that would otherwise be sitting and
adding machines and tabulating onto
paper
and then personal computers emerge in
the 1980s and with them the product
Lotus one two three and one of the
the one and one two three is the
spreadsheet
with lotus you were able to to build
spreadsheets that were interactive
automated and that allowed you to take
the information and turn it into graphs
so this was
a huge advance in bringing data
analytics power and tools
to a lot more people
a lot more powerful form
static data in a ledger or paper
spreadsheet
and then finally
reach the day where you have Excel you
have
a number of other
tools statistical packages and you also
have things like Tableau which allow you
to
create Advanced graphical presentations
it's widely available it's pretty much
democratized
the notion of data analytics and now
it's available it's a field that anyone
can pursue and it's become
extremely important to the digital
economy so I want to impress on you that
data drives the digital economy and data
is
is raw information what really
businesses are looking for are the
insights from that data they need
professionals who can do that work who
can
look at the data figure out which of the
tools are best used to analyze the data
to interpret the data and to extract
usable insights from that data those are
insights about what has happened what is
happening what will happen or what you
should do about it
those are really the areas that
data analytics covers
we talk about how much data there is in
the world a projection that will reach
um
this phenomenal amount of data but uh
another way of looking at it is the
chairman of Google Eric Schmidt said
um
between
the beginning of time and the year
uh
1900 there were five exabytes of data
produced in the whole world in all of
world history we produce five exabytes
of data every two days now
and that just keeps accelerating
especially since the pandemic where our
world has become much more
digital
where much more of what we do is online
or on our mobile devices we have the
Internet of Things where
smart devices from our refrigerators to
our automobiles are producing
information data that needs to be
interpreted
and
there's a process for doing that
it's an interaction between data
analysts data Engineers data scientists
so
data Engineers are the people who
deal with
acquiring and ingesting the data
ingesting meaning turning it into uh
forms that can be processed by digital
systems so
normalization cleaning up missing data
or cleaning up anomalies typos that type
of thing all of that process to turn
data into a
data sets that can be processed by
analytical tools
in this process in this slide we're
talking about data analysis in terms of
looking at that data once it's been
regularized and figuring out where the
insights are so data in analytics and
data analysts need to do this so do data
scientists
data analysts will look at this data try
to figure out what form it's taking and
what types of analytic tools best apply
to it and then draw from a toolkit
data scientists may look at that same
set of data and build new tools so
that's the model development looking at
how new models of statistical analysis
of data analysis and interpret data
they're building data scientists through
that process build the tools that data
analysts will be able to use
machine learning is extremely important
um
now that machines are able to modify
their algorithms based on the data they
receive
so some many of these models many of
these tools will
learn from the new data they acquire and
refine their ability to make
predictions make prescriptive
suggestions
and finally you need to be able to take
the insights and turn them into
visualizations and that's really one of
the key duties of the dating analyst so
this is kind of an overview of what DNA
analytics is and talk about this uh
quotation five exabytes of information
coming between the dawn of civilization
through 2003
and now we create it every two days
um
information is the oil of the 21st
century analytics is the combustion
engine that's one way of looking at it
your saundergard from Gartner where
data drives this latest Industrial
Revolution that we're in
it's been called the fourth Industrial
Revolution and we're really probably
going into a fifth Industrial Revolution
is
the power of data is exploited by uh
artificial intelligence machine learning
and other tools and analytics tools
um Jay bear says we're surrounded by
data but starved for insights and that
is the
he
reason
data analytics is a huge career
opportunity for people
businesses get more and more data but
trying to find the information within
the data is uh
just more and more frustrating more data
you get it's like
expression trying to drink out of a fire
hose where so much data is coming in
that you really need professional
experts who can understand
what part of that data is important
how to turn it into actionable
knowledge and insights
and then finally Hillary Mason
who's a data scientist
says data is a tool for enhancing
intuition and that again tells us that
where many business people learned to
manage on gut instinct
now they're relearning
the necessity to manage based on
evidence and based on what the data
about the real world is telling them
so you may think that something is a
certain way or you may think that a
particular course of action is the right
one but data will
uh help to give you that guy check and
tell you whether your instinct is
correct so
that's the value of this field
Computing sorry for that type of growing
hugely data analytics is growing at a 30
annual rate
um the market for data analytics data
services and the jump in the market is
to 133 billion in 2026 in 19 uh
sorry 2019 seven few years ago it was 20
billion now it's slated to become six
times that size
so
that's kind of the
foundational background about
a data analytics itself
and what
its importances in the world let's talk
about where you can find a place within
that field
thing that most people are interested in
here
and please stay with us we will get get
to your questions and we'll also be able
to tell you about the bonus offer that
you received so
different roles open past the different
data analytics careers and here's here's
a small sampling um data analysts
communicate insights derived from all
kinds of data sources so you might be a
data analyst that's working on climate
information you might be looking at the
economy you might be looking at
demographics you might be looking at um
data from scientific sources or
observations
it's a data analyst is the kind of the
general field and applies in all
different contexts business analytics
business analysts specialize on data
about and derive from business a
business analyst might look at data
external to the business like economic
forecasts and that type of thing and
then they'll combine that with data from
within the business
data about sales revenue customers
production
supply chain all of these different
aspects of information about the
business and then they'll synthesize
that into insights that guide the
business managers the executives of the
company
strategic guidance give operational
guidance and
again focused on the goals of the
business
data scientists
take us kind of a step back or a step
higher in their view of the world as
they'll look at the data and
um
as I mentioned before they'll try to
determine what
new types of analytic models can be used
to understand that data so whereas where
a data analyst might say okay I have a
set of 10 different tools that I can use
and my job is to interpret or understand
what type of data set I'm looking at to
apply the right tool the data scientists
might look at
the new set of data and say I need an
11th tool and I'll design and build that
so
it's a path
that data analysts can move into as you
gain experience and as you gain more
training and education so
we talk about that in terms of different
directions you can go from data analysts
to business analyst or vice versa you
can go from the data analysts to senior
data analyst and move up within that
same vertical jobs
area or description or you can move
diagonally into data science by
increasing your understanding of the
underlying models
and Mathematics and statistics behind
them and then learning how to build
those
so there's a lot of advancement in the
advancement
the growth in the market
is pretty amazing there's a
almost 95 000 93 500 data analysts work
in the US today
the number of data analysts that will be
working in the U.S is going to grow
between now and 2026 by about 20 percent
so that's another
15 to 18 000.
job openings that have to be filled and
companies this is taken off of Glassdoor
just a sampling of companies that are
recruiting now for data analysts Amazon
IBM Wells Fargo
Cisco cognizant Accenture you can see
that it goes across
of many different sectors and in fact
almost every sector of the economy
requires data analytics
to help with their data analytics needs
so this is really a very important area
and depending on what your current
domain experience is you can find
opportunities in your domain
um if you're in financial or if you are
in technology or if you're in marketing
you can find Opportunities to leverage
that if you are looking to get into
another domain
build analytic skills they can be the
key for you to move into that particular
industry sector that you have your eye
on so that's
one of the valuable things about
the the tools that you'll learn as data
analysts
when we talk about value we also talk
about dollars so
uh yeah fairly routine low-level
salaries for data analysts start at 56k
but at the mid level you move up to 70
and if you stay in the job role of data
analyst
as you gain experience you can get up to
100K well if you
work yourself with more skills and
develop your career move into the senior
data analyst role now your salary
uh vertical is
much higher able to do about 50 percent
better
salary if you then continue on and pick
the training and the education to become
a data scientist
you can start opening up even greater
potential so almost double what you
would be able to earn as a data analyst
and so
you have the ability again to move
either laterally or diagonally or
vertically
and build your career as you want it to
go
make
a very lucrative
living for yourself
but you need a cloud to pardon me again
for this type of you need up-to-date
skills to be a data analyst you need to
be familiar with data analytics
statistical analysis using Excel which
is a basic set of tools but very common
I'm sorry very common and uh
available pretty much to everybody
then you want to look at developing more
specialized and more
Advanced tools with things like python
to be able to
build more advanced and more custom
models
or use more advanced Tools in Analytics
including the various python libraries
you need to look at data manipulation
which is part of the data engineering
side of things so you understand how
that feeds into your analytics process
and then you need to look at a
Communications visualization using tools
like Tableau to be able to take the
insights you generated turn them into
something that's accessible to managers
and Executives in your organization
um along the way you'll learn about
things like linear and logistic
regression which are the statistical
methods used for fitting uh data to
models
um within models to different uh
predictive lines and curves
and data analysis in AWS looking at how
data analysis can be applied in Cloud
environments and distributed
environments so that you're able to look
at the modern world of computing which
is very Cloud driven very distributed
where
create a
obtain data across distributed sources
and provide it to users in a distributed
world
and you need to have a number of
different tools so we mentioned Excel we
mentioned python we mentioned AWS we
mentioned Tableau you need to understand
SQL as a method of
organizing the data for your use we also
want to look at things like non-sql
databases so you understand how to deal
with
data that isn't structured that way
um so a lot of different tools that you
need to become
familiar with and proficient in using in
order to be effective
data analyst
so
um at this point I'm going to go ahead
go to our questions and the answers
I'll take a look in the Q a here
I have a couple of people who
how often is this program offered yearly
so you can expect this program to be
offered about once a month
will the slides be available
after the webinar we will send you a
link to the recording of this
presentation so you'll be able to look
at that
uh
okay the presentation addresses deity
engineering
how to prepare data for analytic use
this context is data wrangling the same
same as data scrubbing
so data scrubbing is the Prof is part of
data wrangling
data wrangling is all the different
things you need to do in order to get
data from raw data into a form that can
be used for Analytics data scrubbing is
part of that process so that would be
looking for things like
uh gaps in the data for things like
outliers
that
don't make sense that might be a
spurious reading from a malfunctioning
sensor or that type of
um
it seems data Engineers are the people
who perform
ETL and data architecture
yes data Engineers the people who did
deal with those aspects of
um
acquiring data wrangling the data
preparing it for use by other data
scientists and data analytics
and
been also preparing it for use by
automated systems that will apply those
types of tools to generate things like
ongoing automated dashboards
that is a data engineering role
okay
will you be able to share the slides
from that as I mentioned that we will be
sending a recording of a link to this
recording
uh Michael says I really like working
with and interpreting public sector data
uh like from the government from the US
EPA the Geological Service CDC
what do you recommend for interest in
focusing on interpreting public sector
data so this gets back to the um
distinction I made between data analysts
and business analysts
a business analyst would look at
um
mainly business data data within
generated from within the business or
within the business ecosystem that can
include
public sector data for example you would
want to know about economic data
in order to be able to forecast what
your business's sales demand
going to be in the coming quarters
but if you're looking at the general
question of looking at different data
sources like the EPA and the Geological
Service the scientific sources
um
that
General data and Analysis and
you'd want to look at
you know a program of the type that
we're about to talk about which is
data analytics on a more General level
not focused in on instances the tool
sets are really fairly much the same in
terms of you know you need to understand
what type of data you're looking at how
it relates to things like seasonality
time series things like that so that you
can choose the right set of tools and
this is something that you'll
you'll learn in a program like this one
do you have advice for organizations
that are fairly simple and rudimentary
and use account management systems data
collection
so this is where one of the reasons why
the program
focuses partly on the use of excel
because you're going to find
organizations applications where you
don't need to go into
very Advanced
customized tools the types of tools that
you can use
um by generating models in Excel
will answer the question that you need
is the
Excel as a rudimentary data management
system
and so
that's one of the reasons why we
structured that but also you take a look
at um
rest of the question what metrics are
most important for those organizations
to identify potential opportunities
potentially work with data Sciences to
interpret with the account management
systems again it depends on what is it
that you're attempting to find out if
you look at a
software as a service like Salesforce
Salesforce
provides account management
um collects a lot of data about your
sales process your marketing processes
and even your
uh
revenues and customer interactions and
for people who make purchases
so with that respect you you find
there's a number of tools within
Salesforce that you can use
to um
understand what that data is telling you
uh so you're ability to use data
analytics tools will help you use the
tools in an environment like that in a
tool like or platform like Salesforce to
make the correct decisions about what
data to extract and how to interpret it
you might want to be looking at you know
what are the factors that make a
particular type of customer more
receptive to our sales Communications
what are the seasonalities in our sales
patterns those are the kinds of things
that an account management system can
help
um does data analytics have to gather
the information or do they already have
it that is a really good question
data analytics often deals with uh
existing
data sources that are set up
but an Insight I'll share with you from
an executive in Salesforce in fact who's
in data analytics and decision support
area
um you said you know very often we think
that
our job is for the customer to come to
us the internal customer or user the
sites come to us and say what can you
tell us from this data
and we'll go off we'll interpret data
we'll come back to them with the
insights but
in other instances we go to the customer
and say hey we just found out a new way
of
finding data and interpreting it and we
think it can tell you these things are
those interesting to you
so that's a way that the data analytics
staff the data analysts look for new
sources of data
they might also be called into salt when
something new opens up in organization a
new platform for example creates a new
potential source of data about customers
about operations about interactions so
you might for example in a manufacturing
environment
find new machines being installed on the
factory floor that now have more data
collection capabilities
than the previous generation so now you
have a new set of data
the manufacturing Engineers will know
what what data machines can provide
but they
may not know what tools to use to
interpret that data so they may call on
you say okay this is where the data is
coming from how do we set up a way to
pull it together how will we interpret
it
good
um
a way that you would be involved in
how the data is collected or comes from
is there a beginner's course this is a
beginner's course
we'll be talking about that
uh
every entry-level position for data
analysts or scientists requires three to
five years experience
how does one overcome this hurdle I'm an
electrical engineer transitioning
to the data space
let me offer you
an interesting piece of advice
every entry level position asks for a
certain amount of experience
it does not necessarily require that
amount of experience because
they may not be able to find people with
that amount of experience
and while the HR department they say oh
let's put that into the job description
because that's the kind of people we
want
you may in fact because it's an entry
level position
be able to successfully land that job by
showing off
you have the skills in order to do
enable you to do the work
but that's really one of the ways you
you overcome that by
caffeine practical examples of using the
skills able to show
this is the kind of problem that you
need solved this is an example of how
I've actually done that and solved this
problem
talk about that in a minute
where does machine learning engineering
stand in this hierarchy so it stands uh
into the higher data scientist
um
a little bit of the understanding in
data analytics
um you need to to have an idea about how
the tools can become
self-learning sense that you're using a
model uh about let's say your sales
patterns for sales forecasting and the
more sales you make and the longer the
process runs
the more
accurate the model becomes because of
machine learning capabilities that you
might have built into it so that it
understands that the fit for the
seasonality for example gets better and
better each year
and so machine learning engineering is
something as a data analyst you need to
have a basic understanding of it's
really if you want to be a machine
learning engineer that's a different
specialization uh
part of becoming a data scientist and it
can become
a separate path on its own for AI and
machine learning engineering
uh
uh does SAS provide on the AI and
machine learning and then I don't know
the answer to
um
I need the uh I understand the need
Marilla says I need understand the need
about statistics to apply analytic
techniques
but it would would it be possible to do
other short time courses to achieve that
so there are always
ways to study particular
specific technique skills Concepts
um number of them are available through
uh online self-study videos simply learn
has a whole set of specific courses that
you can also address
um
if you're looking for
a program that will put all of that into
the context of a job role like data
analyst the program we're going to
describe to you
really great option for you so and you
can look at the
picking and choosing bits and pieces and
that's a path that's available if you
want to fill in certain gaps in your in
your toolkit if you want to build it a
robust toolkit more or less from scratch
that's what this program is about
um
data analytics rules remotely for
workers that are not in the US well data
analytics
course is required by organizations all
around the world but if you're looking
to work for a U.S based Corporation
from a remote location either remotely
as in working from home or remotely as
in working one of their Branch offices
data analytics skills are completely
portable in that way
um because of
world we live in where
Cloud interconnects everything and you
can move data
from any part of the world to any other
part of the world almost instantaneously
it's very possible
to fill a data analyst role working
remotely or being in a remote office of
a multinational corporation so
um
are there any certifications classes
that currently exist that will make me
more competitive as a data analyst we'll
be talking about one of those and then
as I mentioned you can look at other
programs if you have that basic
Foundation already and want to add
particular skills there are other
programs that uh
you can ask us about so
how easy or hard is it to change
Industries without relevant experience
changing Industries and changing job
roles are two different things let's
take Industries first
so if you are for example in
Banking and finance and you want to get
into an automotive Manufacturing
one of the things that you would do is
you would take your set of skills that
you use in your job in banking and
finance whatever role it is you're in
and you would look for opportunities in
that other industry that require the
same skills for a similar role even
though it's a different industry it
probably has similar roles and data
analytics is a perfect example of that
are capable of doing data analysis in
the financial sector you'll probably
find
Opportunities and any other given
industry that require that same kind of
data analytics skill
if you're looking to change roles that's
a different thing if you are for example
an engineer and you want to Pivot into
data analytics then you need to gain the
skills so you may want to continue to
work within let us say
um
uh consumer goods Manufacturing
they want to continue within the role of
a manufacturing engineer but you may
want to get more into the quality
control lean stick Sigma those types of
things
you now need to gain analytics
capabilities analytics understanding and
skills so
um you would need to gain more skills in
order to be able to
move into the different roles within the
same industry hope that helps with that
question
or a self-taught data analyst I
sometimes have major imposter syndrome
that don't have a solid statistics
Foundation
so this is a
very good
lead in into the the program we're going
to describe because it will give you the
ability
build up that Foundation understand how
that works and allow you to be more
confident but also more capable in your
data analytics
was having a PhD degree in computer
science make you overqualified
uh not necessarily PhD in computer
science
might make you eligible to pursue a data
scientist role that might be a better
path for you because it's pointed out
earlier you might have a higher
earning potential area but again
the fact that you have a PhD you can
apply that in any way that you see fit
and um
depending on what your specialization
within computer scientists your science
was
uh you know and you're looking at
this field because I presume you're not
interested in being a computer engineer
designing new types of systems
um
so yeah you could
qualify for an analytics job or you
could look at maybe going to the next
level and
becoming a data scientist
um
use the data analytics role for
beginners suitable if I have a career
break for 13 years yes
the sense that as long as you have a
reason reasonable explanation for your
career Break
um that isn't going to cause people to
look at your job history oddly
um but if you're for example if you took
a career break to raise a child and now
you want to move back into a working
World
um
this might be a really great program for
you because
that it is designed for people
take them from level zero on up and I'll
discuss that in a bit but
but the fact that you have a career
break as long as the career break isn't
something odd in itself
um
that shouldn't be a
impediment
I'm searching for a data analyst job
what's your advice for applying to jobs
you don't necessarily have the
experience specific experience with
um
my experience lies with environmental
data but how do I get a chance to
interview with company wanting to
analyze it data for example and here's
the really good thing about that um
first off I'm gonna
share with you something that was said
by an executive with Accenture in San
Francisco
this was about cyber security but it
certainly applies here
this is female executive who is saying
we don't get nearly enough applicants
female applicants for cyber security
rules
the reason we think is that when a male
applicant looks at a job description
and they see that they have 60 percent
of what the job description requires
they will say I might as well apply
um I might get the job
the female applicant is more likely to
say gee I only have 90 percent of what
they're asking for
it's probably not worth applying I won't
get the job
um
the point is that regardless of your
gender
you need to look at a job description as
this is what the
company ideally wants to have if they
could create somebody by Magic
um
can't do that and then
the world we live in technology skills
are still hard to find so
if you have most of what the
lawyer requires as stated in the job
description
you should go for that you should apply
because
the worst thing that can happen is
somebody will say no best thing that
happened is you'll get an interview
again get the job so
going back to the specific question the
average is
if you have experience working with
environmental data and you can show how
there are parallels between the data
that you're working with and the IT data
that you want to work with
you can show how the analytics tools are
pretty much uniform across all domains
and your skill is an understanding
what a particular data set looks like
how to choose the right tool to get the
insights you need from it
then that makes you transferable across
different domains shouldn't feel like
well I know how to
analyze environmental data but I
I'm not sure that means I can analyze it
did you know how to analyze
environmental data the likelihood is
that you have
skills and understanding that you can
transfer to the other domain
uh I hope that answers that question
how important is learning SQL the
learning SQL is important because you're
going to have to understand
in your analytics rules how to access
data that's in a database
pull it out create data sets for
analysis maybe create um
automated
channels
or pipelines for that data so it's
important to understand
um
it's one of the reasons why we cover
that in this program
what can you suggest for Lending
internships or entry-level jobs
part of this program is going to be help
with that but um
I have a skill set in Ai and data
analytics and my field is in electrical
engineering
so one of the things Muhammad that
people recommend works well is to look
for open source projects
do some of those build up a portfolio of
experience because again if you can
demonstrate here are the skills I have
here is how I've applied those skills to
solve this kind of class of problem that
class of problem
can then go to people who have that
show them that you can do the work for
them so that's really a helpful part of
your
education or training process
um I'm from a finance background
interested in data analytics I've
learned tools like Tableau python Etc
and you may
already have much of the background that
this program we're going to talk about
gives you so
you may be looking for a different
solution here but how do you get into
the job market
we do it graduates of this program we do
assist them but um
you probably the same as things said to
Muhammad where you can start taking your
skills your knowledge of these tools and
demonstrate that through doing open
source projects
um that demonstrate
how you use those and your capability
using those to solve problems
graduating in December with a bachelor's
degree of Science and statistics
um
went to one of the big
Hardware companies in Kampala and Uganda
and
director asked me what I can do as a
physician to improve his business in
which position can give me
he told me to go back on Friday with us
so
I hope that you gained a little bit of
insight here and I don't know if I can
give you those those answers that will
get you the job on Friday
but I I would say
and depending on your understanding of
how to apply statistics
through data analysis
um
you can tell him that
your background in statistics your
capabilities will allow him to make
Better Business decisions because you'll
be able to look at information about his
business his competitors his customers
his suppliers and the world around him
and gain insights into
what has happened in the past what is
happening now
what it's likely to happen in the future
and what
um different approaches he can take
change the outcomes in the future those
are the things that
data analytics and the statistics behind
it are able to tell you these statistics
will tell you
based on past patterns this is what we
have seen based on past patterns this is
what is likely happening now
based on past patterns if we project
into the future
we should be able to make the following
inferences about
what's happening or what populations
we're looking at or what trends are
happening
and then based on those past patterns
and the models we have built from them
we can do what if analysis about if I
change this aspect of what I'm doing
what is the likely change in our
outcomes
really
set of things that you should be able to
do for somebody again goes beyond
statistics into using statistics for
Analytics
I hope that is helpful to you and I wish
you all the best luck in getting that
job
um
bachelor's National Security Law
currently working on Google
certification data analytics
background in finance where I work with
a couple of credit unions
um
what specific positions should I focus
based on my experience in education and
learning about having learned about
mortgage and marketing
so very interesting because
um
with data analytics and with things like
the the mortgage and marketing Market
you would be looking at things like what
is the expected rate of home sales in my
area or in United States or in the
country I'm in
um
what is the likelihood of interest rate
fluctuations what are the effects of
interest rate fluctuations on predicted
home sales
um
where would people where would we find
the best Prospect given the situation
the current environment we're in where
would we find the best prospects to
Market our services to all of those
kinds of questions are things that data
analytics can help you answer so
um
hopefully your Google certification will
help you with that we'll be describing
the program in more detail about a more
in-depth approach
um
a switch career from Medical
take a course in data analytics how
could we
approach the resume
again as I said before within any given
domain if you have domain knowledge and
medical and health care
um lots of opportunities for data
analytics in that field so understanding
patient populations understanding
Trends in terms of
Health maintenance
what are the the correlations between
our
patients behaviors and diseases like
diabetes for example
um uh could I be working in the
pharmaceutical industry on the
statistics and Analysis around drug
trials
a lot of different opportunities so
yes you would want to talk about your
experience we want to talk about it in
the context of understanding
how your data analytics skills help you
understand
that area better
what you can do to help people make
better decisions in that area but also
how you're understanding in that area
gives you a general understanding that
you could apply if you wanted to
transfer into a different
having the skills and being able to talk
about how you apply them in one sector
can
often be able to tell the story in a way
that people can see oh yes I understand
how that person can do the same thing
my sector
um changing career paths and getting
into Data analysis and there are no
entry-level positions
I don't believe that that's true I
believe that there are entry level
positions I believe that their entry
level positions because
there are the demand for talent out kind
of outstrips Supply so there's
um
you as I said before you may see a
position listed that says
they require a certain uh it's an entry
level position but it requires a certain
amount of experience
you may
well be able to land that job
by showing how your capabilities
um fit the requirement
how can you find good open source
projects where there are a number of
different
um
places and I can't off the top of my
head name them but
you can actually do a online search
for open source
analytics projects I'm sure you'll come
up with several different sites
that will
give you
different projects to choose from so
uh somebody asked I joined late how will
the recording be available we will send
you a follow-up email with a link to the
recordings
[Music]
what is the easiest way to get
experience using programs like R python
or SQL
I didn't and get a second interview for
a job because I lacked applied
experience you were looking for I will
address that in just a moment but yes
you
you really need applied experience and
this is one of the reasons why
purely learning from self-taught videos
for
self-paced videos uh often doesn't
help you get to that next level of your
career
you need to have experience examples and
I'll talk about one way to do that
how do you distinguish yourself from
other candidates
working as a data analyst applying for a
challenging role from last year but not
getting it through
so again you want to
focus on
being able to show demonstrable skills
demonstrations that
you have done the kind of work that
you're looking to do
if you
need to do
projects as part of a program or open
source then
should focus on that so that you can
build
that portfolio that will distinguish you
from other candidates
I'm going to take a quick look into the
chat because I've reached the bottom of
the Q a
let's see if we've got
questions in there that I haven't
covered so I'm going to take a quick
look
apologize for this
uh
Fatma I do see your question I will
uh take that up with our staff
are there loans to get for these
programs we provide options for
uh
financing but um
we don't provide
loans per se let me
basic math
data scientists or follow
so
the
statistics principles and the
mathematics principles
um
generally
linear algebra and statistics that type
of thing you can come into a program
without knowing those things but you
will have to to learn them my field
Muhammad my PhD is not in the field data
science
built a skill set in data science and Al
I think we've talked about that so
uh
uh how proficient in coding and
programming do you have to be to enter
this field you don't have to enter with
coding proficiency you will gain the
coding proficiency you need if you're in
a good program
um
Shiva says I have a good background in
data analytics
I'm finishing a postgraduate certificate
in AI machine learning what other skills
do you recommend
uh don't know that I would recommend you
need to generate you know more skills
than that if you're finishing your AI
and ml certification you are probably
setting yourself up for a lot of good
opportunities
out there right now so I don't know that
you
um
need to start looking at broadening your
skill set you may want to look at
continuing to deepen your skills in that
particular area but if you want to
broaden your skill set into other areas
um you know you have analytics you have
ai and ml
General data science might help
um
and then you can also look at other
complementary skills
where you would apply this in different
domains so you might look at entirely
different
types of skills that you would
then be able to apply your your AIML
data analytics skills to
uh
uh for companies just starting
getting organized in the data analytics
field what would be the first thing they
should focus on not necessarily
qualified to give you that answer but
you say businesses intelligence maturity
assessment that would be a good starting
point to be able to understand
need to understand what sources of data
are available to you
understand how they come to you
and on what types of scheduler frequency
you need to understand your strategic
and operational goals
and how it would draw on the data that
you need
um you need to identify gaps where to
fulfill those goals you might not have
the data yet and where would you go to
find it
and then you need to look at what tools
and expertise you have available to you
to turn your available data into the
insights that you need to support your
goals so
um
good luck to you with that
are there any AI certifications classes
that currently exist that make you more
competitive
as a data analyst say I.E chat GPT
um so there are
certainly classes from Simply learned
that you can look at there are also
other sources available so
if you contact us we can help you with
some of that
uh
how can we get a deal with the company
or I'll talk about the placement service
we have
not a placement service it is a job
assist service and so let me make that
distinction
see so many people with good portfolio
projects attending multiple even
hundreds of interviews in LinkedIn
uh are you sure
um but yes
again
the demand for data analysts is
extremely high
the difference between data science and
data analytics I think we covered that
and
finish your Master's in public
administration two years ago
and Health and Human Services
everything is very data driven
people here with no degrees but are
familiar with Tableau you could be one
of those people
in terms of you know taking a program
that doesn't require a degree but gets
you into
uh great data-driven jobs within your
organization
um
okay and I think let me see what time
we're looking at it's time for us to to
wrap up
so again I if I haven't gotten to your
question I apologize
um we'd love to to answer that with uh
if you contact us further but I'm going
to ask a question of the audience and
this question is
what is stopping you
right now
from having taken the step you haven't
you know for those of you haven't taken
data analytics certification What
stopped you what is what is the thing
that you've looked at a program but what
didn't
meet your needs
I'll leave this open just for another 10
seconds so get your answers in you can
pick more than one
and I'll close this in five four three
two one
oh
the primary concern people have is not
having practical exposure to practical
experience they can demonstrate their
skills with and then finding or programs
that fit into their
um
schedule and lifestyle so you can see
that on the poll here
now I will
talk about this very briefly I'll just
spend a couple minutes talking about the
Caltech data analytics boot camp so
Caltech has a center for technology and
management education
that helps transfer Knowledge from its
academic side to Industry approached by
companies and said we need your skills
and expertise we need to train our
people in that and they form this
Division and this is one of the programs
that they offer we deliver it on their
behalf on our platform which is a fully
online platform it's been six months you
have some classes that are live online
scheduled for the rest of the material
that you work on the projects and
preparation self-study and that type of
thing that's all available 24x7 so you
can fit it into any time available in
your schedule so pretty much if you can
find the time with a set of classes each
week you can fit the rest of the program
in to any working schedule
the curriculum is very comprehensive you
start off with a kind of an orientation
that tells you how to use these learning
management system where to find your
classes how to get support how to ask
questions
contact our 24x7 help desk and that type
of thing where you'll find your live
classes where you'll find your other
materials
then we do a module on Excel because as
I mentioned that is the basic
uh
tool everybody has
understanding how to use that as a basic
Analytics tool gives you a set of skills
that you can take right out of the gate
then we go into presentations because
so much of what you need to do in data
analytics is to show people what the
insights are that you've generated in a
way that they can understand
understanding how to do that through a
clear and concise presentation is very
important
understanding SQL again talked about the
importance of knowing where and how to
find the data understanding python so
that you can start looking at more
advanced tools than what is available in
Excel and able to build more advanced
analytics tools for yourself
then we look at Tableau as
I wonder if you said
see people around you who know Tableau
have skilled in Tableau and they're
moving ahead when you're not so this is
again one of the most important parts
about
modern powerful visualization
implication tools then looking at how
data analytics works in the Cloud
environment we use AWS for this course
the same principles apply to Azure
Google cloud and others
then you do a final project which ties
together everything you've learned
in the course and the final project lets
you create
in addition to all the other projects
you've done along the way it creates the
Jewel Crown Jewel of your portfolio
where you can say this is the problem I
chose to solve this is how I built the
solution
you build the solution on your own but
with guidance from instructors so that
if you get stuck or if you start going
down a rabbit hole you can
get help in Direction and going the
right way but you end up with something
that you can point to and say I did that
showed that off to potential employers
this program does not require prior
technology knowledge or coding
experience
what you need to learn about technology
about mathematics about
programming you will learn as part of
the program
do not have to have work experience so
you can come into this from any other
field you don't have to come in feeling
like I well I have to be
a data analyst for two years to do this
you can come straight out of high school
if you want to but of course if you're
already
bachelor's degree and been working for a
number of years this program will also
help you pivot into data analytics or
gain the skills of data analytics that
will help you develop your career
so I'm going to ask the question how
much experience do folks in our audience
have
see that I can't launch this Poll for
some reason
hold on a second let me see if I can fix
that
one moment
let me see if this will work
it is not letting me launch polls
this is not good
one moment here
all right
uh having a small malfunction with zoom
so we'll skip the poll questions I'm
going to go ahead and tell you about the
career assist service because I
mentioned that earlier the fact that you
are able to get this is for users in the
US I apologize for if you're not out
you're outside the U.S but this allows
you to get six months of job assistance
support with a custom job board
available as well as resume rewrite
service and
interview practice service
um another we had one individual who's
taken the course from the UK
again I apologize that we don't offer
this outside currently we're working on
fixing that
um
you also get of course the real world
projects for your portfolio
that you've developed during the program
and access to other webinars and events
that we
run so I would love to ask you this
question and I will try to ask you this
question
but I don't know that I will be able to
ask you this question
why this is not happening
for a second here
okay oh I know why it's not happening we
reached after the hour so it's not
letting me do that I apologize
um
so let me just share with you the
program fees
which are ten thousand dollars flat but
if you mentioned that you went to this
webinar and start in the cohort where
classes start in May
you will receive a 500 discount off of
the price of the program
and of course you can Finance the
program over time and equal monthly
installments
so
it'll be less than 880 a month after you
claim your discount
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and I am going to put that into the chat
I am hoping that Zoom will not kick me
out
I'm going to put into the chat right now
here is the email address and the link
to our program page
get that and we will be sending you a
follow-up email with a link to this
presentation
and
we will be sending uh
we hope we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with
Caltech and with simply learn
use the QR code to get to the program
page please do email us at ask us to
simplylearn.net and we will provide you
with
uh information answer your questions
help you get enrolled help you claim
that discount so again thank you so much
we look forward to seeing you in this
program with Caltech and simply learn
that concludes the webinar
foreign